we're becoming cyborgs
and uh there's an interesting interplay
between wires and biology
um
you know zeros and ones and the
biological systems and i don't think
you can just
i don't think we'll have the luxury to
see humans as disjoint from the
technology we've created for much longer
we are in organisms that's um
yeah
i mean i
agree with you
but
we come really with this to
consciousness yes and is there a
distinction there because what you're
saying the natural end point says we are
indistinguishable that if you are
capable of building
a
an ai
which is
sufficiently close and similar that we
merge with it then then
to all intents and purposes that ai is
conscious as we know it um
and i don't
i don't have a strong view but i have a
view
um
and i i wrote about it in the epilogue
to my last book because ten
years ago i i
wrote a chapter in in a book called life
ascending about consciousness and the
subtitle of life ascending was was the
10 great inventions of evolution and i
couldn't possibly write a book with a
subtitle like that that did not include
consciousness
and specifically consciousness
uh as one of the great inventions
and it was in part because i was just
curious to know more and i read more for
that chapter i never worked on it but
i've always how can anyone not be
interested in the question um and i was
left with the feeling that hey nobody
knows and b
there are two main
schools of thought out there
with a big kind of skew in distribution
one of them says oh it's a property of
matter there's an unknown law of physics
pan psychism everything is conscious the
sun is conscious it's just a matter or a
rock is conscious it's just a matter of
how much
and i find that very unpersuasive um i
can't say that it's wrong it's just that
i think we somehow can tell the
difference between something that's
living and something that's not
and then the other the other end is it's
a it's an emergent property of a very
complex central nervous system
um and
i am
i never quite understand what people
mean by words like emergence i mean
there are genuine examples but i think
we very often tend to
um use it to to plaster over uh
ignorance
as a biochemist the question for me then
was okay it's a it's a concoction of a
central nervous system
a depolarizing neuron gives rise to a
feeling to a feeling of pain or to a
feeling of love
or
anger or whatever it may be
so what is then a feeling in biophysical
terms in the central nervous system
which bit of the wiring gives rise to
and i i've never seen anyone answer that
question in a
in in a way that makes sense to me and
that's an important question to answer
i think if we want to understand
consciousness that's the only question
to answer because i you know i i
certainly a an ai is capable of out
thinking and it's only a matter of time
maybe it's already happened in terms of
just
information processing and computational
skill
i don't think we have any problem in
designing a mind which is at least the
equal of the human mind
but in terms of what we value the most
as humans which is to say our feelings
our emotions are
our
sense of what the world is in a in a
very personal way
um that i think means as much or more to
people than their information processing
and that's where i
don't think that ai necessarily will
become conscious because
i think it's the property of life well
let's talk about it more you're an
incredible writer one of my favorite
writers so let me read
from your latest book transformers what
you write about consciousness
i think therefore i am said descartes
is one of the most celebrated lines ever
written
but what am i exactly
and artificial intelligence can think
too by definition and therefore is
yet few of us could agree whether ai is
capable in principle of anything
resembling human emotions of love or
hate
fear and joy
of spiritual yearnings
for oneness or oblivion or corporeal
pangs of thirst and hunger
the problem is we don't know what
emotions are as you were saying
what is the feeling in physical terms
how does a discharging neuron give rise
to a feeling of anything at all
this is the heart problem of
consciousness
the seeming duality of mind and matter
the physical makeup of our innermost
self we can understand in principle how
an extremely sophisticated parallel
processing system could be capable of
wonderous feasts of intelligence but
we can't answer in principle whether
such a supreme intelligence would
experience joy or melancholy what is the
quantum of
solace i
speaking to the question of emergence
you know there's just technical um
uh
there's a there's an excellent paper on
this uh recently about
the um this kind of phase transition
emergence of performance in neural
networks on the
problem of nlp natural language
processing so language models there
seems to be
this question of size
at some point
there is a phase transition as you grow
the size of the neural network so the
question is
that's sort of somewhat of a technical
question that you can philosophize over
the technical question is is there a
size of a neural network that starts to
be able to form
the kind of representations that can
capture a language and therefore be able
to
um not just language but linguistically
capture knowledge that's sufficient to
solve a lot of problems
in language like be able to have a
conversation and there seems to be
not a gradual increase but a phase
transition and we in the they're trying
to construct the science of where that
is like what is a good size of a neural
network and why does such a face
transition happen anyway that that sort
of points to emergence that there yeah
there could be
stages where
a thing goes from being oh you're you're
very intelligent toaster
to a toaster
that's feeling sad today and turns away
and looks out
um out the window
sighing having an existential crisis
thinking you're marvin the paranoid
android is that well no marvin is
simplistic because marvin
is just cranky
yes
uh it's so easily programmed yeah easily
programmed non-stop existential crisis
you're almost basically uh what is notes
from underground but dusty likes is just
just constantly complaining about life
no they're
capturing the full
roller coaster of human emotion the
excitement the bliss the connection
um the empathy and all that kind of
stuff and then the selfishness
the the anger
the the depression all that kind of
stuff capturing all of that
and be able to experience it deeply like
it's the most important thing you could
possibly experience today the highest
highs the lowest lows this is it my life
will be over this
i cannot possibly go on that feeling and
then like after a nap
you're feeling amazing
that might be something that emerges so
why would a nap
make
an ai being feel better
the
first of all we don't know that for a
human either right but we do know that
that's actually true for many people
much of the time you may be
depressed
when you do in fact feel better so
oh you are actually asking the technical
question there is there uh so that's a
very there's a biological answer to that
and so the question is whether ai needs
to have the same kind of attachments to
its body and bodily function and pres
preservation
of the brain's
successful function
of
self-preservation essentially in some
deep biological sense
i mean i to my mind it comes back round
to the problem we were talking about
before about simulations and sensory
input and learning what all of this
stuff means
and life and death
that that biology unlike society has a
death penalty over everything and
natural selection works on that death
penalty that if you make this
decision wrongly
you die
and
the next generation is represented by
beings that
made a slightly different decision
on balance
um
and that is something that's
intrinsically
difficult to simulate in all this
richness i would say um
so so what is
death in all its richness yes
our relationship with death
or or or the whole of it so which when
you say richness of course
there's a lot in that yeah which is hard
to simulate
what what's the what's part of the
richness that's hard to simulate
uh i suppose the
complexity of the environment and your
position in that or the position of an
organism in that environment in the full
richness of that environment over its
entire life over multiple generations
with changes in
gene
sequence over those generations so
slight changes in the makeup of those
individuals over generations but if you
take it back to the level of single
cells
um which i do in in in the book and ask
how do
how how does a single cell
in effect know it exists as an unit as
an entity i mean no in inverted commas
obviously it doesn't know anything um
but it acts as a unit and it acts with
astonishing
um
precision as a unit
um and and i had suggested that that's
linked to the electrical fields on on
the membranes themselves and that they
give some indication of how am i doing
in relation to my environment as a kind
of real-time feedback on the world
um and this is something physical
which can be
selected over generations that if you
are
if you get this wrong
um
it's linked with this set of
circumstances that i've just won
as an individual
i have a moment of blind panic and run
um as a bacterium or something you have
a you know some electrical discharge
that says blind panic and it it runs
whatever it may be and you associate
over generations multiple generations
that this electrical phase that i'm in
now
is associated with
a response like that and it's easy to
see how feelings come in through through
the back door almost with with that that
kind of
um
giving real-time feedback on your
position in the world in relation to
how am i doing and then you you
complexify the system and yes i have no
problem with a with with phase
transition and i you know
can can all of this be done
um
purely by
the language by the the the issues with
how the system understands itself
maybe it can i honestly don't know
um but i i you know the philosophers for
a long time have talked about uh the
possibility that you can
have a zombie intelligence
uh and that there are no feelings there
but all everything else is the same um
is i mean i have to throw this back to
you really how do you deal with the
zombie intelligence
so first of all i can see that from a
biologist's perspective
you think of all the complexities that
led up to the human being
the entirety of the history of four
billion years that in some deep sense
integrated the human being into this
environment and that
dance of the organism and the
environment
you could see how emotions arise from
that and their emotions are deeply
connected
creating a human experience and from
that you mix in consciousness and
the fullness of it yeah
but
from a perspective of an intelligent
organism that's already here
like a baby that learns
it doesn't need to learn how to be a
collection of cells or how to do all the
things he needs to do it's
the basic function of a baby as it
learns is to interact with its
environment to learn from its
environment to learn how to fit in to
this social society to like um and the
the basic uh response of the baby is to
cry a lot of the time cry uh to uh well
maybe convince the humans to
to protect it
or to discipline it to teach it what if
i mean uh we've developed a bunch of
different tricks uh how to get our
parents or to take care of us to educate
us to teach us about the world
also we've constructed the world in such
a way that it's safe enough for us to
survive in and yet dangerous enough to
learn the valuable lessons like the
tables are still hard with corners so it
can still run into them it hurts like
how
so ai needs to solve that problem not
the problem of constructing this super
complex organism that leads up
uh
so you to run the whole
um
uh you know to make an apple pie to
build the whole universe you need to
build the whole universe i think the the
zombie question is uh
it's something
i would leave to the philosophers
because
uh and i will also leave to them the
definition of love and what is
what happens between two human beings
when there's a magic
that just grabs them like uh nothing
else matters in the world and somehow
you've been searching for this feeling
this moment this person your whole life
that feeling
um
the philosophers can have a lot of fun
with that one and also say that that's
just uh you you could have a biological
explanation you can have all kinds of
it's all fake it's uh actually ein rand
will say it's all selfish there's a lot
of different interpretations i'll leave
it to the philosophers the point is the
feeling
surest health feels very real
and if my toaster
makes me feel
like it's the only toaster in the world
and when i leave
and i miss the toaster and when i come
back i'm excited to see the toaster and
my life is meaningful and joyful and the
friends i have around me
get get a better version of me because
that toaster exists
that sure as hell feels i mean
is that psychologically different to
having a dog
no because
i mean most people would dispute whether
we can say a dog i would say a dog is
undoubtedly conscious but uh but but
some people will but there's degrees of
consciousness and so on but people are
definitely much more uncomfortable
saying a toaster yeah conscious than a
dog
and
there's still a deep connection you
could say our relationship with the dog
has more to do with anthropomorphism
like we kind of project the human being
onto it maybe we can do the same damn
thing with a toaster yes but you can
look into the dog's eyes and you can see
that it's uh it's sad that it's it's
delighted to see you again i don't have
a dog by the way i don't know it's not
that i'm a doctor dogs are actually
incredibly good at using their eyes they
do just that
they are now i don't imagine that a dog
is remotely as close to being
intelligent as a as an ai
intelligence yes but um
it's certainly capable of communicating
emotionally with us but here's what i
would venture to say we tend to think
because ad plays chess well yeah and is
able to fold proteins now well
that it's intelligent i would argue that
in order to communicate with humans in
order to have emotional intelligence it
actually requires another order of
magnitude of intelligence it's not easy
to be
flawed
solving a mathematical puzzle is not the
same as
the full complexity of human to human
interaction that's actually
we humans just
take for granted the things we're really
good at
non-stop people tell me how shitty
people are driving
no
humans are incredible at driving uh
bipedal walking walking object
manipulation we're incredible at this
and so people tend to
discount the things we all just take for
granted and one of those things that
they discount is our ability
the dance of conversation and
interaction with each other the the
ability to morph ideas together the
ability to get angry at each other and
then to miss each other like to create
attention that makes life fun and
difficult and challenging in a way
that's meaningful that is
a skill that's learned and ai would need
to solve that problem i mean in some
sense what you're saying is
a ai cannot become meaningfully
emotional let's say until it experiences
some kind of internal conflict that is
unable to reconcile these various
aspects of reality or its reality
with
with a decision to make
and then it feels sad necessarily
because
it doesn't know what to do
and i i certainly can't dispute that
that may very well be how it works i
think the only way to find out is to do
it and just build it yeah and leave it
to the philosophers if it actually feels
sad or not the point is the robot will
be sitting there alone having an
internal conflict an existential crisis
and that's required for it to have a
deep meaningful connection with another
human being now does it actually feel
that i don't know but i'd like to throw
something else at you which which
troubles me uh on reading it um
uh noah harari's book 21 lessons for the
21st century and he's written about this
kind of thing on various occasions
and he sees biochemistry as an algorithm
and then ai will necessarily be able to
hack that algorithm and do it better
than humans so there will be a.i better
at writing music that we appreciate the
mozart ever called or writing better
than shakespeare ever did and so on
because
biochemistry is algorithmic and all you
need to do is figure out which bits of
the algorithm to play to make us feel
good or bad or appreciate things
and it's a as a biochemist i find that
argument
close to irrefutable and not very
enjoyable
i don't like the sound of it that's just
my reaction as a human being you might
like the sound of it because that says
that ai is is capable of the same kind
of
uh emotional feelings about the world as
as we are because the whole thing is an
algorithm and you can program an
algorithm
and and there you are
he then has a peculiar final chapter
where he talks about consciousness in
rather separate terms and he's talking
about meditating and so on and getting
in touch with his inner conscience i
don't meditate i don't know anything
about that
but he wrote in very different terms
about it
as if somehow it's a way out of the
algorithm
um now
it seems to me that consciousness in
that sense is capable of scuppering the
algorithm i think in terms of the
biochemical feedback loops and so on it
is undoubtedly algorithmic
but in terms of what we decide to do
it can be much more
um
based on an emotion we can just think i
don't care i can't resolve this complex
situation
i'm going to do that
and that can be based on in effect a
different currency which is the currency
of feelings and something where we don't
have very much personal control over and
then it comes back around to to to you
and what you what are you trying to get
at with ai do we need to have some
system which is capable of overriding
uh a rational decision which cannot be
made because there's too much
conflicting information by
effectively an emotional judgmental
decision that just says do this and see
what happens
that's what consciousness is really
doing in my view yeah and the question
is whether it's a different process or
just a higher level process
i might you know
the idea that biochemistry is an
algorithm
is uh to me an over simplistic view
there's a lot of things that
the moment you say it it's irrefutable
but it simplifies
i'm sure it's an extension and in the
process
loses something fundamental so for
example
calling a universe an information
processing system
sure yes
you could you can make that it's a
computer that's performing computations
but you're
missing
uh the
the process of
the entropy somehow leading to pockets
of complexity that creates these
beautiful artifacts that are incredibly
complex and they're like machines and
then those machines are through the
process of evolution are constructing
even further complexity
like
in calling universe information
uh processing machine
you're
you're missing those little local
pockets and how difficult it is to
create them so the question to me is if
biochemistry is an algorithm how
difficult is it to create in a software
system okay that runs the human body
which i think is incorrect i think we're
that is going to take so long
i can't i mean that's going to be
centuries from now to be able to
reconstruct a human now what i would
venture to say to get some of the magic
of a human being
with what we saying with the emotions
and the interactions and like like a dog
makes us smile and joyful and all those
kinds of things that will come much
sooner but that doesn't require us to
reverse engineer the algorithm of
biochemistry yes but
the toaster is making you happy yes
it's not about whether you make the
toaster happy um no it has to so
it has to be
it has to be the toaster has to be able
to leave me happy yeah because it's the
toaster is the ai in this case is a very
interesting the toaster has to be able
to be unhappy and leave
me that's essential
yeah that's essential for my being able
to miss the toaster if the toaster is
just my servant
that's not or a provider of like
services
um
like tells me the weather makes toast
that's not going to deep connection it
has to have internal conflict you write
about life and death it has to be able
to be conscious of its mortality
and the finiteness of its existence
and that life is for it was temporary
and therefore it needs to be more
selective one of them
hangs out moving moments in the movies
from when i was a boy was the the
unplugging of hell in 2001 where
that was the death of a sentient being
and
hal knew it
so i think we
we all kind of know
that
that a sufficiently
intelligent being is going to
have some form of consciousness but
whether
it would be back like biological
consciousness i just don't know and if
you're thinking about how do we bring
together i mean obviously we're going to
interact
um more closely with with ai
but
are we really
is is is a is a dog really like a
toaster or is there really some kind of
difference there you were talking ab you
know biochemistry is algorithmic
but it's not a single algorithm and it's
very complex of course it is so it may
be that there's there are again
conflicts in the circuits of
biochemistry but i have a feeling
that the level of complexity of
the total biochemical system at the
level of a single cell is less complex
than the the level of neural networking
in the human brain or in an ai
well i guess i assumed that we were
including the brain in the biochemistry
algorithm
because you have to
uh i would see that as a higher level of
organization of neural networks they're
all using the same biochemical wiring
within themselves
yeah but the human brain is not just
neurons
it's the immune system it's it's the
whole package
i mean to have a biochemical algorithm
that runs a
uh intelligent biological system you
have to include the whole damn thing and
it's pretty fascinating it comes from
like
from an embryo
like the whole i mean oh boy
i mean if you can um
what is a human being
because it's but if you look just some
code and then you built and then that so
dna doesn't just tell you what to build
but how to build it
is it
i mean the thing is impressive and the
question is how
uh
difficult is it to reverse engineer the
whole
shebang very difficult i i would say
it's
don't want to say impossible but
it is
like it's much easier to build a human
interverse engineer
to build like a fake human
human-like thing
than to reverse engineer the entirety
the process the evolution and
i'm not sure if we are capable of
reverse engineering the whole thing yeah
if our if the human mind is capable of
doing that i mean
i wouldn't be a biologist if i wasn't
trying yeah um but
i know i can't understand the whole
problem i'm just trying to understand
the rudimentary outlines of the problem
there's another aspect though you're
talking about developing from a single
cell to a to a to the human mind and all
the
part system subsystems that are part of
the immune system and so on
um this is something uh that you'll talk
about i imagine um with uh with michael
levin
but
so little is known
about you talk about reverse engineers
so little is known about the
developmental pathways that go from a
genome to going to a fully wired
organism
um and a lot of it seems to depend on
the same intellect
electrical interactions that i was
talking about happening at the level of
single cells and its interaction with
the environment there's there's a whole
electrical field side to biology
that is not yet written into any of the
textbooks
which is about how does an embryo
develop into our single cell develop
into into these complex systems what
defines the head what defines the immune
system what defines the brain and so on
that really is written in a language
that we're only just beginning to
understand and frankly biologists most
biologists are still very reluctant to
even
get themselves tangled up in questions
like electrical fields influencing
development it seems like mumbo jumbo to
a lot of biologists and it should not be
because this is the 21st century biology
this is where it's going uh but we're
not going to reverse engineer a human
being or the mind or any of these
subsystems until we understand how this
developmental process is well how
electricity and biology really works and
and if it is
linked with feelings and with
consciousness and so on
that's the standing in the meantime we
have to try but but i think that's where
the answer lies
so you think uh it's possible that the
key to things like consciousness
or some of the more
uh tricky aspects of cognition might lie
in that early development
the interaction of electricity and
biology
electrical fields but we already know
the eeg and so on is telling us a lot
about brain function but we don't know
which cells which parts of a neural
network is giving rise to the eeg we
don't know the basics the assumption is
i mean we know it's neural networks we
know it's multiple cells hundreds or
thousands of cells involved in it and we
assume that it's to do with
depolarization
uh during action potentials and so on
but the mitochondria which are in there
have much more membranes than the plasma
membrane of the neuron and there's a
much greater membrane potential and it's
formed in
parallel very often parallel christie
which are capable of of
reinforcing a field and generating fuels
over longer distances
and nobody knows if that plays a role in
consciousness or not there's reasons to
argue that it could but frankly we we
simply do not know uh and it's not taken
into consideration you look at the the
structure of the mitochondrial membranes
in the brains of you know simple things
like drosophila uh the fruit fly and
they have amazing structures you can see
lots of little rectangular things all
lined up uh in in in in amazing patterns
what are they doing why are they like
that we haven't the first clue
you